my god like where did this year go
because it feels like the past two years
have just like flown by i mean 2020 just
disappeared in a flash obviously because
everyone was just inside and depressed
but like this year i feel we were able
to go out a little bit more at least in
japan we're able to go out a little bit
more than last year but i think in our
case we just had so much [ __ ] going on
that it all just like seems like a blow
i mean i was i thought i was busy in
2020 and then 2021 was like allow me to
introduce myself and then yeah every
like you know on the uh on the iphone
calendar yeah yeah like when you have
something on the iphone calendar like
you have something on that day there's
like a little dot to symbolize it so
yeah it's very easy on iphone to see how
busy your past couple of months worth
because every month i came up to the
next month and i was like yeah i'll be
i'll be a lot more free next month like
this month was super busy next month
though no dots enter that month
all dots yeah
it's like oh cool i had three days off
last month no wonder i'm [ __ ] tired
yeah it's it was really
surreal seeing just your calendar fill
up because i remember when i first moved
to japan i i thought who needs a
calendar we're youtubers we don't need
calendars we make our own schedule you
move to japan and slowly you're just
like maybe i need a calendar just to
like keep track of like one or two days
and then more stuff keeps creeping in
and you just like oh wait i need to put
my personal life on my calendar as well
because like now i don't know when like
my mates want to hang out if i have
something going on that day yeah yeah
you know it's like
it's so surreal just being this busy and
i never expected to be this busy in my
life i mean it's definitely a good thing
right like you know it's a very uh
it's a definitely a very privileged
position i would say to be busy and
doing all sorts of cool stuff but like
at the same time you know it's only so
much my body can handle you know that
scene in like every like business movie
where the ceos like put it in my
calendar i i thought that was just a
cliche
oh do i have time for this meeting put
it in my calendar i tell you a matter of
time until we all have our own deborah's
they have the pencil [ __ ] in for us
i think so i i i ironically want an
assistant yeah right
i know that sounds terrible i thought
like what the [ __ ] i would never want
one then i'm like oh actually you know a
lot of things could be helped but if i
had someone who helped schedule things
yeah i know a couple of like youtuber
friends who live here that have like
personal assistants and i'm like oh my
god that seems like a [ __ ] life i
just oh man the thought of having to
like speak to someone
[Music]
and be like hey my life's a mess can you
help me like it's not about that like
i'm i'm i i i feel i don't know how to
explain it i'm embarrassed about having
to get my life in order you know what i
mean that's what it is so it's like
going to the doctor i like i want you to
tell me that i'm [ __ ] at health like i
know that but if i go to the doctor you
i'm gonna have 100 confirmation that i
am unhealthy i just don't want to be
that guy who's like talk to my pa yeah
let me say like if you want to like uh
get permission for stuff or get like i
don't know
you're like okay i need to be able to
like arrange all the [ __ ] can you help
me do that yeah uh but like i mean some
days like i don't know about three three
four days of the week i pretty much fill
my schedule up from literally like eight
eight o'clock to like midnight yeah it's
like yeah
good stuff doing stuff but i like that i
like doing it and live streaming has
added a bunch of time that it needs to
be squished i mean you've put more work
on yourself this year because i feel
like this year is the year that you've
really upped your live stream live
streaming schedule
has like you you basically have almost
like three channels now you've got trash
taste you've got
your channel
you've got your live stream channel
right yeah because now i'll do live
streams in the morning or the evening so
if i'm not doing something in the
morning like let's say if i have
something at 12 o'clock like you know
like we record trash today we did it at
11. yeah right but if we did it at 12 i
would be like all right sick i wake up
at eight i'll live stream until 12. i'll
come here yeah and then i'll like work
all day and then i'll go do something in
the evening and then i'll sleep this is
why i can't watch shows actually this is
what i've realized i literally yeah
i i don't know what joe's excuses i'm
like streaming until i sleep so i
realized i have no time to watch i
literally have to pencil in the times i
watch anime now right because because
here's here's like the he's like the
ultimatum of every anime youtuber right
yeah because a lot of the times it takes
more work to make a video about an anime
than to watch an anime so i actually
have to pencil in okay this is the time
i'm going to put in into making a video
about anime and here's the time that i
have to pencil in to watch anime and
like the time of penciling to watch
anime is like it's like this the time of
penciling to make videos is like that
yeah this is like the equivalent like
doctors having to like study new
practices to stay on top of that game
yeah i have to watch animation i just i
just want to r d i just love to think
that like you know if i was like i'm
like you know if someone was like a maid
of gods i was like hey god you want to
like hang out on x day or next time and
god's just being like
sorry man that's anime time
actually
literally there have been times where
sydney's like uh gone can we we hang out
on this night and i'm like sorry sydney
it's my anime watching night it's part
of my job i i need to keep up with like
what's get what's airing right now my
friends laugh at me because i have to
like ask them i have to like i send them
email no like invitations to like times
to like hang out yeah yeah let's hang
out i'll send you an email yeah
to like put it in your calendar yeah
because i'll forget you send them like a
google calendar notification i think
about like the last 10 times i agreed to
hang out with someone at least on like a
call not like in person i i've never
like not turned up in person but my
on-call to hang out with people who are
like i don't get to see often or people
live in other countries yeah i think
like the last
five out of ten that i didn't put in my
calendar i think i like turned up late
or just forgot about yeah if i don't put
it in tonight i feel terrible about that
i'm about a bad friend but yeah if if i
don't put it in my calendar because
because sometimes sometimes you get like
free time or you think you get free time
you're like
do i actually have free time so you say
you whip out the calendar and you're
like oh i do have free time then an hour
passes and you get a message and you're
like oh weren't you meant to be we're
meant to have a call caller we meant to
be hanging out you're like oh
[ __ ] it's a lie it's so big it's a lie
for me it's like for me the problem is
like you know going back to like the
apple calendar thing i'm like all right
that finally i wake up and i'm like
finally a day where the dot is
non-existent i have a day off i can do
whatever the [ __ ] i want but then i go
to my computer i look at my other
schedule that's sitting at my desk and
i'm like oh
i have to edit three videos and do two
sponsors all right so it's not a day off
it's a day to be inside but i'm not
necessarily doing anything outside so
it's not a day off
and uh yeah that's been my life for the
past did you guys have to-do lists
yeah i've been starting to like do to-do
lists now because i have to forget what
i have to do to do list when i the day i
discovered to-do lists like to do it
like
like a caveman jumping over a rock yeah
a game changer there was a list of
things i had to do with it
i don't even think cavemen were that
impressed when they discovered fire like
well i because like one of my friends
honestly dude like especially when it
comes to our stuff because because we
have so many things that we have to do
and so many things that we want to do
yeah right so
my dad actually taught me like how to
make the perfect to-do list which is you
wake up in the morning and you think to
yourself all right you jot down
everything that you can think of that
you can do and that you have to do
you jot it down and then from that list
everything that is super important goes
to the top yeah everything that
everything else that can wait a couple
of days goes to the bottom yeah and then
you go on with your day you tick off
everything that you do and at the end of
the day if you're left with a couple of
things that's all right that becomes the
top of your to-do list the next day
right and just i've been doing that for
the past year and i've become
infinitely productive like i i guarantee
that's what mood on does as well
probably with the americans
i'm like how do i find more hours in the
day move down you you seem to like pull
from this infinite pool of hours that i
don't know where you find i don't want
to me immortals aren't meant to have
that level i throw away my humanity long
ago we don't want to wield that level
i just want to know what did mudan
sacrifice you know what
i think like how did it cost everything
i think he hooked his like brain in
cardo like brain and heart to a car
battery it was just like constantly just
going
i can't wait to come on and explain
himself it's like just don't sleep
like when you talk to him he's awful at
like explaining how he's productive like
he doesn't make it sound realistic he's
just like yeah you know i just wake up
in the morning i just do it yeah he's
the epitome of just get good yeah you
like with mood on i only see like the
input and output like input editing work
outputs a video i don't see like what
happens it's basically just like a black
box right it's like the youtube
algorithm because like you kind of know
how it works but no one really knows the
inner workings of the youtube algorithm
that's just like mudan and editing for
me man have you ever seen mudan edit
the only time
i've seen in him
is on stream and that's where he's also
doing something else but he's probably
like holding back on streams as well as
people don't get freaked out
sorry
honestly that's how impressive it is
because it's like i i think you know
people already know who watch the show
are aware of just how much he edits the
trash taste and also for me and connor
but i think people forget that you know
other people also ask him to edit oh
he's he's actually working for sydney
now as well yeah right so i'm just like
and not to mention he edits his own
streams and he streams and he also
streams and he also streams like pretty
regularly so i'm like what how the beast
man i would like to know what i do mudan
what is your scene when you come on when
you come on you can tell us please
please
wait an episode we're also waiting for
the country to open back up which
hopefully will finally happen next year
as well
that's the biggest thing i'm hoping for
um i think it'll i mean it's gonna
happen next year it's just when it's
like is it gonna happen early or late
that's that's the you know that's the
big question i think everyone is saying
uh like as early as maybe feb or march
right i think much would be nice
visitors can coming in because right now
i think uh if you're a non-visitor so if
you're like a student or you're on work
fees or stuff like that you can
technically come in now yeah um not that
i've seen any actual examples of people
coming in well i assume they need to get
real i haven't looked into the process
but i assume they need to reapply for
some kind of problem application
yeah um because you know not tourists
but at least if you have a working visa
or you've been waiting
for like a job or to study here then you
can come here which is which is good
which is like it shouldn't have taken
two years to get to this point
um i feel bad for the students man yeah
i know right just being like finally i
get to live my dream of coming to japan
no it makes me feel so bad because like
when we applied we have to wait like
what three months and that was just like
the worst three months right because
it's not it's not the fact that it's
three months it's the fact that it's
three months where you don't know what's
going to happen in your life and you're
just like your life is kind of in limbo
until you get that confirmation to be
like oh okay finally i can start packing
i can start preparing to go and then but
while you're waiting you're just like uh
should i start should i go what's kind
of going on with my life right now i was
wondering with the students thing i was
thinking like okay we had no way of
knowing that it's going to take two
years for japan to open yeah and and
like
i don't know what i i haven't really
spoken to any students about it but like
what was like if you got to like you're
like day one right you find out japan's
closing like do you just like wait and
see or do you just decide to do
something else and then like hope and
hope that you can just then go back i
don't know i think i think for most
students i don't think anyone was
anticipating
them to [ __ ] stay in limbo for two
years right so i'm sure the majority of
students were like oh you know i you
know i still got time i can wait imagine
two losing two years of like i guess
progress you could have made in your 20s
yeah yeah but then again it's not it's
not really that important because i
guess a lot of people in life didn't
start doing the their main thing until
they were like 40. so i guess it really
doesn't [ __ ] yeah yeah sure i mean but i
think what sucks is that you just have
two years where you can't really commit
to something you know that's that's what
really sucks for me where i i always
want to have a goal that i'm working
towards and know that i'm actively
working towards that goal because one
one one of my biggest pet peeves is like
if i feel like i'm not working towards
something then i just feel lost and i
just feel like a [ __ ] lost soul and i
need i need i need something concrete to
work towards yeah that's why i like i
really empathize to anyone waiting for a
visa and thank god you guys can finally
come here hopefully you get here soon
get to eat some superman
that's the number one thing [ __ ] the
sushi [ __ ] the ramen go to your local
skimming joint and discover true
happiness